it's not just that we have to fix this
politically we obviously do we have to
keep breaking the machine and everything
else but we also must build new things
at Russell Brand who we started with
about an hour and 20 ago was also on Joe
Rogan talking about how the more the
sensorious machine gets the more
sensorious the machine gets the more
that it will allow for alternative
things to rise and uh yes I agree
but they they do things to get
people to self-censor of course and
Rumble doesn't do that it was that well
yeah exactly what was difficult for us
when we when YouTube was our primary
platform is something we would look at
your content all right that's the title
of this Rogan video um this is the
content okay well we can try that and
then we would get demonetized and it
becomes like a weird algebra you change
this word you change that word you have
to order it you have there's certain
things you just and you know that you
can't say and you still get some money
from like YouTube Red yeah you still get
but it was like they were doing things
and I mean I they were running a
business I understand from their
perspective of course you know they're
running a business they have advertisers
I understand it from their perspective
but from a Content creation perspective
you just couldn't trust them this is
what uh Rumble of fundamentally offered
they gave me a good deal and the
Assurance That We're Not Gonna censor
you now obviously coming from where I
come from politically and in terms of my
background even as a person has been in
the public for a while I'm like I know
how rumble's being portrayed it's being
portrayed as a right wing like we're
getting far right place conspiracy
theorist yeah you and Glenn Greenwald
super far Road yes like this married gay
Pulitzer Prize winning I'm a journalist
Tulsi gabbard super right word yes like
it's nuts it's nuts what people call it
it's just anything alternative to the
censorship model they'll talk of as
right wing but you guys get it you will
always be framed as a right-wing maniac
and any new product that comes in and is
effective will be framed as four
right-wing crazy people or buy
right-wing crazy people or anything else
but I would much rather be with the
right wing crazies who actually aren't
that crazy easy then the leftist
lunatics who have set this entire game
up so that everything that we all hold
dear and precious will be destroyed
foreign
[Music]